[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
brigitte bourguignon bonjour bonjour
c'est beaucoup d'être avec nous mais des
délégués chargés d'autonomie on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représentée par
stéphane bern est bonjour stéphane
bonjour stéphane qui dirige le bureau
parisien du journal ouest france
on va commencer bien sûr en parlant du
vaccin de cette stratégie vaccinale qui
pose question plus de cent mille
français qui sont désormais
vacciner mais un rythme qui est toujours
un peu long olive et veyran s'engage à
ce qu'un million de français soient
vaccinés d'ici la fin du mois de janvier
est ce qu on est quand même dans un
gouvernement qui gère la pénurie
éventuelle de vaccins alors d'abord on
ne gère pas la pénurie les doses sont là
nous savons que nous avons déjà le
million de doses annoncée 500 milles qui
sont livrés chaque semaine donc nous ne
gérons pas une pénurie mais nous gérons
par contre une stratégie une stratégie
avec un produit qui n'est pas si simple
d'utilisation qu'on voudrait bien le
penser et donc avec cette stratégie
développée nous avons d'abord et nous
assumons d'avoir commencé par les
personnes les plus âgées les plus
vulnérables qui sont je le rappelle pour
certains sont celles qui ont payé le
plus lourd tribut lors de la crise
sanitaire chacun pouvait s'émouvoir des
morts en ehpad aujourd'hui lorsqu'on
commence par eux parce que c'est eux qui
développent la maladie la plus
aggravante est souvent mortelle bien sûr
qu'il est normal que nous commencions
par cette population ainsi que pour les
personnes âgées à domicile qui vont
suivre
cette stratégie a été élargie vous le
savez pour accélérer les choses à au
personnel soignant de plus de 50 ans et
aussonne au moins de 50 ans qui
présentent des comorbidités et puis
aussi aux sapeurs pompiers et se savait
bien aussi que ça pour effet de booster
les chiffres depuis quelques jours
aujourd'hui on est passé à 139 mille
quasiment 138 1450 pour être précise
hier et nous allons continuer sur 7 sur
cette ligne là pour atteindre peut-être
même 400 milles en fin de semaine des
centres de vaccination s'ouvre sur les
territoires qui s'adresseront donc à ces
personnes à ses personnels notamment du
domicile de plus de 50 ans et pour les
autres qui ont des comorbidités ces
centres de vaccination vont se
multiplier
pour l'instant il y en a 200 il y en
aura à peu près 350 en fin de semaine
pour aller jusque 6 ans à la fin du mois
donc voilà toute cette stratégie voyez
vous se met en place et a pour effet
bien sûr de booster les chiffres et
400000 à la fin de la semaine c'est
l'objectif numéro un c'est l'objectif
alors vous dites y'a pas de il n'y a pas
pénurie à gérer il ya quand même ya
quand même eu un retard à l'allumage en
tout cas moi je me souviens de jean
castex qui au moment de la présentation
de la politique vaccinale gouvernement
annoncée des livraisons très clair avec
des volumes très chiffré disait
notamment qui avaient 1,160 un million
cent soixante mille doses qui devaient
être livrés d'ici la fin de l'année là
vous nous dit on à un million il ya
quand même un décalage
m il n'y a pas de décalage aujourd'hui
ce qu'il annonçait ce qui s'est fait la
joie de lire les rattraper les doses
sont là je voudrais qu'on arrête avec
ses problèmes récurrents en france qui
sont toujours en train de nous toujours
finalement trop de s'auto flageller
les doses sont là les ehpad sont prêts
aujourd'hui même on va aller sur
finalement les personnels qui n'était
prévue qu'en février
nous avons remonté le calendrier pour
permettre à ces chiffres de monter moi
je trouve qu'on devrait passer son temps
plutôt à essayer de sensibiliser ceux
qui sont encore sceptiques les
personnels aussi très souvent qui sont
encore sceptiques face à la vaccination
aujourd'hui on a leur audience blanc des
personnalisations notamment de personnes
d'après l'instant on a 20 % de personnel
qui acceptent la vaccination par
endroits c'est pas suffisant d'autres
endroits par contre accepte largement
par exemple dans les milieux
hospitaliers c'est quelque chose de plus
courant
nous sommes aujourd'hui sur cette
problématique il faut régler parce que
oui on a un cordon sanitaire à faire
autour des personnes âgées aujourd'hui
autour des personnes vulnérables que
nous ciblons à travers cette première
vague de vaccination est donc il ne
faudrait pas qu'on est un maillon
manquant dans cet édifice
il faut donc continuer à sensibiliser
ses demandés par exemple j'étais en
visioconférence hier avec les
fédérations de domicile tout comme
vendredi et que les fédérations d pad
qui vous le disent nous avons encore à
convaincre notre personnel qui commence
à regarder moi je les ai rencontrés je
suis allé visiter cinq ehpad qui
démarrent leur vaccination en seine
saint denis à montfermeil
à saint-omer dans le pas-de-calais où
laventie extérieur et j'ai parlé de ses
personnels j'ai entendu elle disait on
attend un peu
le recul nécessaire le recul est là le
recul est là puisqu'on nous mais
suffisamment les chiffres des autres
pays en évidence
nous savons aujourd'hui qu'il n'y a pas
de victimes vous savez bien comme moi
que s'il y en avait on le saurait très
vite donc aujourd'hui ce recul est là la
vaccination n'a pas d'effet nocif sur
les personnes au contraire donc nous
devons renforcer cette vague de
vaccination comme l'expliqué olivier
ferrand lui-même a reconnu qu'il y avait
sûrement eu de sa part un déficit de
communication en estime d'explication
est ce que par exemple au gouvernement
on va faire une campagne de publicité en
faveur du vaccin est ce que c'est prévu
alors moi je ça m'est demandée en tout
cas donc nous irons probablement faire
une campagne de sensibilisation à la
vaccination parce que moi je salue
d'ailleurs il ya pas mal d'élus locaux
qui le font il y a pas mal aussi de
mouvements qui se sont organisés en
disant je me vaccine et vous oui il y
aurait non allemagne national de l'as
far de rabat brillante campagne
nationale jeu j'en ai parlé hier avec
les fédérations qui le demandent je leur
ai demandé aussi à elle de déployer ce
type de publicité entre guillemets
auprès de leur personnel bien sûr star
vous savez les réticences viennent
parfois de vieilles peurs qu'on s'est
créé ou du fait que pour une fois nous
avons d'abord un virus que personne ne
connaissait qui nous a fallu apprendre à
connaître d'un vaccin qui mondialement a
été boostée aussi parlé tous les
chercheurs qui se sont rassemblés pour
le faire je pense qu'on devrait
s'enorgueillir de ce résultat aussi
rapide et c'est peut-être cette rapidité
qui a perturbé mais voilà il faut
maintenant qu'on travaille là-dessus
pour convaincre tous ceux qui peuvent
déjà avoir accès aux vaccins d'y aller
déjà le ministère de la santé a
communiqué sur le nombre de personnes
vaccinées en france est fière 138000
français vaccinés 11 11 janvier donc les
choses démarrent par contre dans les
vaccinations sont à peu près également
répartis sur l'ensemble du territoire
pas de souci sauf que les outre-mer sont
très peu représentés la guadeloupe 96
vacciner la martinique 159
est ce que c'est normal ou est ce qu'il
ya une difficulté particulière sur
d'autres maintenant il n'y a pas de
difficultés
même eu les stratégies dont on parlait
beaucoup militaires qui ont été déployés
pour vaquer pour apporter la logistique
nécessaire dans ces départements
il ya encore du travail peut-être de
conviction et d'organisation à voir là
j'ai pas encore les remontées je suis
pas en mesure de vous donner plus
d'information là dessus mais nous allons
nous y pencher sur le calendrier avant
de parler des ehpad la vaccination
débute lundi pour les plus de 75 ans on
va y revenir on va en parler avec vous
mais à quand le début pour les plus de
65 ans est ce qu'on peut s'attendre à un
début à la fin du mois alors moi j'ai le
calendrier actuel que je peux vous
communiquer et qui est celui que vous
connaissez c'est à dire que nous avons
donc ces personnels dont nous parlions
de plus de 50 ans ce qui est une
commodité et les plus de 75 ans à partir
du 18 janvier
ce qui est important de rappeler quand
même à nos auditeurs c'est qu'une
plateforme s'ouvre à partir de jeudi
pour prendre rendez-vous dans les
centres de vaccination qui s'ouvre qui
sont déjà connus sur cette carte qui
vous est communiquée lorsque vous vous
inscrivez vous n'êtes pas obligé d'aller
dans un centre dans un autre vous pouvez
aller dans le centre qui vous convient
celui qui est le plus en proximité de
votre domicile d'ailleurs l'idée c'est
quand même
il nous en avons beaucoup discuté avec
les directeurs des ars et les préfets
coreca réuni le premier ministre
vendredi soir par visio et nous allons
beaucoup nous appuyer évidemment sur le
local le territoriales parce que rien ne
serait pire que de ne pas être en
proximité sur une campagne qui va
s'adresser à chacun mais cette course
c'est à dire concrètement comment vous
allez vous à pied pour les plus de 75
ans qui nous écoutent aujourd'hui qu'est
ce qu'il doit faire concrètement pour
leur ivoire être voilà ce que je vous
disais les plus de 75 ans doivent aller
s'inscrire sur ce site mais ils peuvent
être aidées il ya un numéro de téléphone
aussi pour ceux qui téléphonent à
numéros et communiqué
à partir de jeudi ce sera en place et
est opérationnel et vous vous inscrivez
dans le centre qui vous convient et
alors vous pouvez être aidée aussi par
les gens qui passent à domicile pour
vous conseiller
nous avons demandé hier aux fédérations
de relayer ce message aussi
et dédé le cas échéant les personnes à
domicile qui ne sauraient pas ce serait
une manière numérique de ce prise de
rendez vous est ce que vous êtes en
mesure de dévaluer à peu près la demande
est ce que vous savez s'il va y avoir
une demande très forte des plus de 75
ans dès jeudi où vous avez vous avez des
indicateurs à peu près les indicateurs
je n'en dispose pas mais par contre ce
que je sais c'est qu'il ya vraiment une
volonté d'aller se faire vacciner chez
ces personnes durant une demande forte
on parle toujours des plus de 75 ans en
les imaginant uniquement incapable de se
mouvoir vous savez très bien comme moi
qu'elles se déplacent qu'elles ont une
vie sociale qu'elles sont très souvent
bien sûr valide et c'est tant mieux
et quelles elles vont faire comme elles
font d'habitude quand elles prennent un
rendez vous chez le médecin ou il y à
aussi l'aide par exemple le dr libre par
moments sur certains départements qui
sont déjà organisées en ce sens et donc
voilà vous avez beaucoup de souplesse le
médecin est peut-être près de chez eux
là vous le disait avoir en fin du mois
de janvier si centre par gc seulement
facile 6 marc département du coup donc
cela sera pas forcément à proximité du
domicile de ces personnes âgées à ce
qu'elles vont être aidé pour aller se
faire vacciner est ce qu'il ya des
choses qui sont mises en place
alors si vraiment elle ont un problème
de déplacement ce qui n'est pas souvent
le cas je l'espère car ce qui peut être
le cas
vous savez il ya des communes qui par
exemple plutôt que d'être dans la
critique propose déjà je les salue et je
salue les élus locaux qui s'impliquent
et certains ont déjà pensé à
l'organisation de navettes
éventuellement par leur ces crs ou par
d'autres structures
donc pour à alet les bains vers les
départements voilà mais tout ça est en
train de s'organiser nous avons une
réunion ce midi aussi avec les élus
locaux qui nous feront leur remontée en
fait c'est de la co construction en ce
moment de façon à ce que cette campagne
de vaccination
le premier nice est engagé est ce
qu'elle soit transparente vous voyez
nous vous communiquons les chiffres et
puis à ce qu'elle soit de proximité
gratuite et de libre accès donc je pense
que tout ça est en train de se mettre en
place c'est quelque chose qui ne s'est
jamais fait d'une manière aussi rapide
dans un pays
nous avons toujours fixé ce calendrier
sur trois mois voire un peu plus pour
vraiment arrivé
aux 15 minutes personnelle et vous
assurer que tous les plus de 75 ans qui
souhaitent être vaccinés le saurons est
ce que c'est les départements qui vont
surveiller ce à travers leurs fichiers
comment ça va se passer il y a le couple
qui a bien fonctionné si j'ose dire
pendant la crise sanitaire qui est celle
du préfet et du directeur de rs qui sont
là pour nous faire c'est remonter et
être dans vigilance bien sûr sur les
territoires mais je pense aussi par
exemple à d'autres populations
auxquelles on pense moi et là on aura
besoin des élus locaux on travaille déjà
avec eux ce sont les personnes isolées
qui sont l'objet nos attentions
d'ailleurs en particulier moi je veux
qu'on bâtisse une stratégie là dessus
parce que les personnes isolées
on a vu pendant les plans canicule là
pendant cette crise sanitaire il a fallu
recourir à beaucoup de stratagèmes pour
les atteindre
et pour aller les rencontrer donc celles
ci seront à surveiller particulièrement
je reviens là la demande qu'on évoquait
tout à l'heure est ce que vous êtes
prêts à faire face à cette demande est
ce que est ce qu'il faut s'attendre à
des abords de la tente dans un certain
nombre de centres délais importants
c'est possible que s'il ya une très
forte demande
il y ait des délais d'attentes comme
pour un rendez-vous quelque part le tout
étant que nous nous préoccupions chaque
jour de savoir si ses demandes ne recule
pas dans le temps et en vue la landriais
raisonnable pour vous ce serait un
délais d'attentes raisonnable c'est pas
plus de huit jours
d'accord pas plusieurs jours maintenant
si c'est beaucoup plus alors il nous
faudra aussi nous appuyer sur d'autres
structures comme centre de vaccination
peut-être qu'il ya aussi par exemple moi
j'ai un territoire très rural
beaucoup de communes rurales peut-être
que les centres de vaccination seront
avoisinants adossé aux hôpitaux mais
pour autant au milieu de ces territoires
il n'y a pas d'hopital donc il faudra
bien que par exemple on s'appuie sur des
maisons de santé extra donc tout ce
déploiement va aller en de cette manière
là souriant ce débat est ce que ce
déploiement pourrait s'appuyer plus sur
les élus locaux il y en a beaucoup qui
sont demandeurs vous avez vos questions
qui sont à l'initiative et qui sont
plutôt positifs dans la démarche mais
aussi de ceux qui critiquent en disant
pourquoi est-ce qu'on fait pas appel à
nous on sait faire on peut aider
alors chacun vous en êtes de la relance
je pense que chacun ses compétences et
que justement les mains tendues doivent
être prises bien sûr et c'est ce qu'on
est en train de le faire d'ailleurs dans
le déploiement territorial de cette
stratégie vaccinale
quand on parle des établissements vous
le savez ça se passe entre ars et puis
professionnels de santé et mais quand on
parle du domicile là ça devient plus
diffus plus compliqué à organiser c'est
là où nous allons résoudre les adultes
bien sûr et c'est pourquoi nous
travaillons déjà sur cette stratégie qui
va être déployé sur tous les
départements et même au plus près des
territoires etc on y travaille bien sûr
avec eux et tous ceux qui ont des
propositions sont bien sûr regarder de
près parce que ça nous intéresse au
contraire c'est beaucoup plus
pragmatique on va parler plus
spécifiquement des ehpad on va revenir
bien sûr à la question du vaccin mais un
mot d'abord sur ce variant britannique
qui inquiète fortement qui on imagine
inquiète dans les ehpad est ce que du
coup le protocole va être à nouveau
renforcée pour éviter la propagation de
ce variant dans les ehpad
alors ça rejoint toutes les questions
qu'on s'est posée avant d'abord la
nécessité de se faire vacciner soi-même
et puis l'entourage qui vous est proche
et puis ensuite ça pose la question du
protocole moi je fais toujours un peu
frileuses à ur confinement total d'un
établissement à partir du moment où les
gestes sanitaires sont respectées ou les
précautions d'usagé sont là je pense
qu'il est quelquefois plus nocif encore
d'isoler totalement une personne âgée
ce que j'ai entendu de mes retours
d'expérience tout de suite à ma
nomination
c'était ça c'était surtout que d'accord
il a fallu protéger de manière
sanitaires ces personnes pour qu'il n'y
ait pas de propagation du virus mais ce
que j'ai surtout entendu c'est que
beaucoup d'entre elles se sont laissés
glisser parfois parce que l' isolement
était trop pas supportable aujourd'hui
ce qu'elle nous dise et elles veulent
retrouver une vie normale
elles veulent retrouver une vie sociale
elles veulent que leurs enfants puissent
revenir les protocoles ont été
assouplies vous savez quand même que
pour autant nous restons vigilants bien
sûr et les directions d'établissement
doivent prendre les mesures
proportionnées évidemment et donc il ya
des droits de visite maintenant bien sûr
toujours un peu régularisés par des
rendez vous pris quelquefois des timings
un peu serré je trouve pour des familles
qui sont éloignés qui n'ont pas la
possibilité de voir leurs parents
donc on s'arrange pour que on protège
sent isolé c'est un peu m modification
du protocole dérouleront à l'heure
actuelle au niveau national est-ce que
territorialement il peut y avoir
des durcissements bien sûr damman dans
l'est par exemple et voilà si par
exemple il ya un cluster évident dans un
établissement
il appartient aux directeurs de prendre
les mesures qu'il convient de prendre
mais dans la majeure partie du
territoire
nous on va les directeurs et c'est de
maintenir ce lien social très important
notamment lorsqu'il approché dans et
troubles cognitifs sur la vaccination
combien de résidents des ehpad ont été
vaccinées à l'heure actuelle parmi ceux
qui le souhaitent et ça représente quel
pourcentage parmi tous les résidents des
ehpad ne se fait à peu près trente mille
résidents là à l'heure actuelle qui ont
été vaccinées il y aura une montée en
charge de ces de ces chiffres là puisque
maintenant pardon les remontées en
consentement sont là et que nous savons
exactement combien de doses il faut par
établissement ça nous permettra de faire
un pointage plus affinée pour avoir dans
les jours qui viennent trente mille
résidences et les 30000 sur combien
comme résidents dépendants france il y à
peu près un million de résidents en
france donc c'est ça commence et tout
public confondu c'est à dire que on
n'assimile pas souvent mais il faut
l'assimilé il ya aussi la résidence
autonomie résidence personnes âgées qui
ne disposent pas des mêmes systèmes et
qui ont des logements plus autonomes et
bien tout ce public là sera aussi visés
maintenant donc il faut dans votre plan
de charge quand est ce que quand est ce
que les millions de résidents sera
couvert c'est théoriquement on s'était
fixé ça pour le mois de janvier
théoriquement c'est le but poursuivi
parce que c'est sale évidence la
différence entre maintenant et hier
c'est que maintenant les doses sont
arrivés la plupart du temps dans les
établissements ça va être déployée moi
j'ai quelques calendrier je sais que les
ehpad de ma circonscription qui sont
dans un certain flou ce sera le 27
janvier ça ils ont un calendrier déjà
ils me l'ont ils me l'ont dit il
souffrait voilà vous nous parlez d'une
remontée de consentement c'est
l'expression vous avez employé ça veut
dire que au début de la campagne de
vaccination
très peu de résidents des pâtes souhaité
être vaccinées on en est aujourd'hui non
c'était pas cette question là c'était
que bien sûr qu'il faut demander l'avis
des personnes notamment lorsqu'elles
sont en établissement et que maintenant
les réticences sont fortes les
réticences n'était pas fort mais parfois
vous avez des gens alors il ya beaucoup
de populations dans ces établissements
qui sont des populations troubles
cognitifs ou qui ont perdu la faculté
parfois de donner leur propre
consentement et ça il faut en tenir
compte c'est pas simple donc ce sont
soit les personnes de confiance qui
donnent leur consentement ou la famille
lorsqu'il n'y a pas de personnes
désignées et ça prend un peu plus de
temps c'est pas le formalisme qui a pris
du temps parce qu'il n'ya pas de
formalisme n'y a pas trop ce moment
écrit j'ai vu ça et là des initiatives
qui ont été prises et qui ne sont pas du
fait de directive qui tout à coup des
médecins en demandant des consentement
écrit jamais on leur a demandé de
demander des consentement écrit mais
pour autant oui ça prend un petit peu de
temps que d'expliquer à la personne mais
c'est parce qu'ils freinent un
approvisionnement je vois sur là dessus
et le visite vous disais c'est que dans
certains établissements il ya que 20% du
personnel qui souhaitent se faire
vacciner est ce que ça c'est pas un
autre problème important ce que
j'imagine que ce personnel il un rôle
prescripteur très fort
si vous n'avez que 20% du personnel qui
se fait vacciner bien que 80% du
personnel a priori opposés à la
vaccination
du coup dans les conseils ou les
recommandations que c'est le personnel
va donner aux homos pop aux résidents
qui les écoutent
il peut y avoir un effet très négatif
alors honnêtement les remontées que j'ai
les directeurs font leur job informent
correctement les résidences ta
consentement éclairé dont on parle là au
delà de dire et le personnel des
soignants bonne jamais ils ne font part
de leur sentiment aux résidents je
précise bien les choses
il reste à les convaincre il n'ya pas
d'anti vaccins au milieu de ses
personnels mais ils restent parfois une
indécision une petite angoisse certains
mêmes vont jusqu'à me dire je préférais
tel vaccin plutôt qu'un autre
voyez on a tellement eu d'information à
profusion sur les noms des vaccins qui à
l'arrivée
que certains même voudrait privilégier
le vaccin français qui n'arrivera que
l'année prochaine je dois ya un moment
où il faut le chien qu'il ya aussi
est-ce que vous disposez aujourd'hui
pour les convaincre le désire on parlait
de campagne de communication et au delà
de ça vous avez d'autres d'autres
leviers il n'y a pas d'autres leviers
que la sensibilisation parce que nous
sommes dans un pays où neuf anti lisent
pas et on laisse le libre choix aux
personnels donc c'est dans le dialogue
c'est toujours comme ça c'est pareil sur
le vaccin antigrippe vous avez peu de
personnel qui se font vacciner c'est
aussi le fait que tous ne peuvent pas se
faire vacciner à l'heure actuelle vous
le disais l'art et la vaccination est
réservé aux plus de 50 ans on va écouter
à ce sujet de directrice d pad dans leur
elle s'appelle nous ramino il était au
micro de samia de chirel à une question
pour vous êtes vous prête à élargir et à
ouvrir la vaccination à toutes les
personnes toutes confondues jeunes et
moins jeunes à domicile ou en structure
oui alors c'est une question qui est
posée très souvent le choix de la
priorisation il est très clair
aujourd'hui bien sûr dès lors que nous
aurons atteint cette première cible le
plus largement possible avec toutes les
conditions qu'on vient de se donner
c'est à dire celle de persuader et de
continuer à convaincre
eh bien on passera tout de suite à
l'autre phase qui est celle des
personnes au delà de l'âge qui est
prescrit la main quand ce sera en
février mars nous allons être sur cette
prolongation du calendrier au et bien
sûr un élargissement à tous les
professionnels juste un dernier mot sur
les ehpad sur les réserves parce que
pour vacciner il faut du matériel il
faut des gens aussi on visait qu'il ya
des difficultés de personnel dans les
ehpad comment ça se passe alors la
difficulté de personnel elle est
récurrente moi je les ai connus dès mon
arrivée aux affaires sociales en 2017 il
y avait une crise des ehpad
nous avons beaucoup travaillé sur ce
sujet dans l'urgence sanitaire en
renfort avec beaucoup de vecteurs
différend avec pôle emploi on a signé
des conventions avec elisabeth bornes
pôle emploi une circulaire notamment qui
a été adressée aux directeurs des ars et
au pôle emploi
le résultat c'est que nous avons eu 30
mille demandes d'emploi qui ont été
satisfaites
entre le domicile et les établissements
donc ça veut dire que d'abord il ya un
vivier d'emplois conséquent dans ce
domaine du prendre soin
et qu'il faut il travailler nous avons
aussi activer le lien avec l'insertion a
connu l'assertion économique aussi
l'insertion des personnes plus éloignés
de l'emploi nous l'avons fait avec
brigitte klinkert aussi on est allé par
exemple dans un établissement à caen qui
a déjà une convention en insertion et
qui permet à des personnels un peu
éloignés de l'emploi d'entrer
directement dans ces formations
l'idée c'est que de l'urgence n'est
aussi l'appétence est que nous arrivions
aussi à créer toute une filière d'emploi
qui mérite d'être évidemment rendue
attractive par le salaire et par les
conditions qu'on y met et en dernier mot
sur la loi autonomie stéphane oui à un
séminaire gouvernemental sur de demain
demain matin vous allez y participer il
sera question de réformer ce qu'on peut
encore conduire des réformes
à ce stade du quinquennat dans ce pays
et si oui est ce que la loi autonomie en
fera partie
moi je peux pas vous donner de
précisions sur le calendrier que vous
imaginez bousculé nous sommes mieux
d'une crise sanitaire nous et toute
notre énergie en sortir de cette crise
sanitaire donc évidemment il va de soi
qu'un calendrier parlementaire ne peut
pas sortir totalement indemne d'une
telle crise sanitaire mais pour autant
nous n'avons pas tous les arbitrages à
l'heure où je vous parle le travail est
conséquent depuis six mois déjà à la
fois sur le métier à la fois sur les
décisions qu'on peut prendre aussi sur
le domicile et la proche domiciliaire et
nous aurons les arbitrages en du projet
l'instant je n'ai pas l'ordre du jour y
compris aux personnes ne l'ad'ailleurs
au gouvernement sait par exemple que la
loi climat arrive le 10 février
oui mais elle n'y a pas su amelia de
date pour la loi autonomie pour
l'instant non avant la présidence jeunes
alors je vous parle je ne peux pas vous
dire quelles seront les arbitrages de
demain et je me refuse d'ailleurs elle
est donnée puisque aucun de mes
collègues mais capable de vous dire à
l'heure où je vous parle
quels seront les arbitrages finaux de ce
que je sais en tout cas du président de
la république sait que sa volonté
réformatrice est là qu elle est toujours
là et que la crise sanitaire n'a rien
nous beretz et faculté à réformer le
pays
merci beaucoup merci aux jeunes
bourguignons jamais venu nous voir ce
matin stéphane on regarde la une de
responsables nation énergétique les
aides
un vrai casse tête c'est à la une de
votre journal ce matin merci stéphane
merci madame la ministre on passe au
titre au club de taille
[Musique]